OpenClaw is a proactive autonomous agent
formerly known as Claudebot and Maltbot.
This powerful runtime allows you to host
a personal assistant that can execute
real world tasks such as managing your
calendar, triaging emails, and
controlling smart home devices directly
through messaging apps like Telegram and
Discord. This course will teach you how
to set up and use OpenClaw. You'll learn
how to connect leading AI models, manage
persistent long-term memory, and expand
the agents capabilities using different
skills. By the end, you'll have a
persistent 247 AI operator that
automates your digital life while
ensuring your data remains entirely
under your own control. Kian created
this course.
>> Hello and welcome to this free code camp
course. My name is Kian and in this
course I'm extremely excited because
we're going to be learning Open Claw
which is the project that has taken the
open source world by storm. And by the
end of this video you'll have the grasp
of the basic features of OpenClaw so
that you can go deeper into the more
advanced functionalities. So when it
comes to prerequisites for this course,
the prerexis I assume is that you've had
experience using a CLI before because
the CLI is the main way that you
interact with OpenClaw and therefore we
need to be able to run commands.
However, even if that's not the case, as
long as you follow the commands that I
do, then it should be fine and dandy.
And then also I'm assuming that you've
had exposure to LMC before and have
maybe interacted them with them through
an API have done some prompt or context
engineering because we need to be able
to understand many different parts of
the context in this repository because
openclaw is essentially managing context
in a very smart way to accomplish
different workflows. You've probably
seen how it can do WhatsApp, Discord,
Slack, etc. So these are some of the
basic requirements but otherwise this
course should be relatively
straightforward to follow and what
actually is this course. So let's go
through the nine different modules.
First of all we're just going to do a
quick recap of what openclaw is. Then
we're going to do the installation.
We're going to talk about the workspace
and memory which is to say how is the
agent defined. Then we're going to be
doing a module on pinchboard which is
just like molt book essentially a social
media for agents. Then we're going to be
making our own personal assistant.
Looking into skills, which is very
similar to Claude skills. Then multi-
aent, which is very useful because it
allows you to customize multiple agents.
So you can have one agent that is maybe
for work, another one that now is for
personal. This is just an example. Then
we're going to be diving into security
and after that sandboxing, which is also
related to security. So the first module
just discusses what OpenClaw is. So if I
make my camera smaller and make this
text bigger, OpenClaw is a self-hosted
messaging gateway that connects
WhatsApp, Telegram, Discord, etc. to
coding agents. The one word here that is
slightly confusing is gateway because it
is a very reoccurring theme in the open
claw repository. What does it mean? It's
a single longunning process on your
machine that maintains persistent
connections to different platforms. In
this case, we're we're just talking
about the messaging platforms. So you
can think of the gateway as this long
running process that whenever a message
arrives for example, it routes it to an
agent that can do some execution or do
some manipulation on that input. Maybe
you have a workflow where every time
your employer sends you a message, you
tell them that I'm sick or something
like that. Then the gateway is what
handles this. And what this allows you
to do is self-host the entire stack
because you essentially are owning the
connections, the config and the
execution environment. Another valid
question is how is opencloud different
from cloud code? Because if you've seen
the terminal user interface, the TUI, it
looks kind of like cloud code. The
difference is that open cloud once again
is fully self-hosted on your machine and
it has many more supported integrations.
For example, claude code has Slack, but
just as we mentioned before, we have
WhatsApp, Telegram, Discord, and many
others that are supported natively with
OpenClaw and more being supported every
single day. And overall, it's just much
more configurable and you can do a lot
more with it as opposed to cloud code.
So that would be what I say is the main
difference. Quick little FYI, all of the
resources displayed in this course can
be found at this repository, open claw
course and the GitHub pages is the same
URL, but just in the GitHub pages
format. So if you're looking to read
through any of the resources that I go
through in the course, that is all at
the following link. So now we can just
get straight into the installation. And
for this all you need is a node version
greater than node version 22. So if I
check my node version right now, it
should be the latest version which is I
believe 25 right now. Otherwise there
isn't much else to have. One thing that
is very important however is running
this on a local machine versus on a
virtual machine or a VPS virtual private
server. So this choice is important
because in essence when you download
OpenClaw you're giving the agent access
to your entire computer and root access
on all of your files. So in theory the
main risk is a prompt injection where
maybe some malicious actor tells your
agent to delete everything from the root
directory. Well in that situation you
are out of luck because the agent
literally has terminal access and can do
that exact execution. So for that
reason, many people are running these on
VPS's because in that case, you have
everything on a different server where
you don't have any files which you
really care about if anything goes
wrong. But for that reason, it is just
more complicated and it does not allow
for certain functionalities such as
browser use. So since we're not going to
be doing anything that will get us into
any security vulnerabilities in this
video, I'm going to be hosting this
locally on my Mac. However, if you are
concerned with the security
vulnerabilities, I highly recommend
setting this up through a virtual pirate
server. And there are many good
tutorials on how to do this currently.
Otherwise, we can just go and install
this with node package manager. The g
flag meaning install it globally so that
we can call open claw from anywhere in
our terminal. So, I've already done this
installation. It shouldn't take that
long to verify that we have everything
there correctly. And then once we've
done the installation, we run the
onboard command. But you'll also see
that the onboard has this extra tag
called install demon. And the install
demon flag installs the gateway as a
background service. So launchd on Mac
OS, systemd on Linux, whatever,
whatever. What this means is that the
gateway starts automatically on boot and
keeps running. You don't need a terminal
open. And now we're going to run the
onboarding wizard to walk us through the
config path, workspace location, and
channel pairing. So let's start this
right away. Okay, you can see that it's
been activated. And if I bring my
terminal up, what do we have here? We
have first and foremost the security
warning, which once again emphasizes the
possibility for really bad outcomes if
you're not careful. So in order to
prevent this, one thing you can do is
run these security audits or do the
sandboxing in addition to running this
on a virtual pirate server. And
interestingly, using a more powerful
model is more secure because they are
more resistant to these prompt injection
schemes. If you're using Quen 4B, for
example, a small 4 billion parameter
model, then it is much more susceptible
to prompt manipulation since it's just a
smaller model. So, one thing once again
that I'd recommend is to use the most
powerful model capable so that if
there's ever some malicious intent that
the model can prevent it from happening.
So, we must understand that there are
risks. And then let's go through the
manual configuration to go through every
single option. And we're just going to
reset all of my configurations so that
my config is like yours. Of course, this
reset section won't come up for you, but
everything else should be the same. So,
how do we want to set this up? There we
can do it either as a local gateway,
which is this machine, or remote gateway
if you're doing this on another device.
So, as we already mentioned, we're going
to do this locally in this video. And
then we need to install workspace
directory which installs all of our open
claw related files and this is just by
default in our useropenclaw directory.
So we don't want to touch that. And then
when it comes to the model there are
many options we have open anthropic and
Google of course if you'd like to do
this for free then Google flash 3 which
is a very capable model is actually free
for 20 requests per day. So you can set
this up if you just want to try this
without paying anything. But Anthropic
is known to be quite good. So if you do
have the option, I would choose
Anthropic. And then with respect to the
token, there are many ways to get it.
The setup token is just generated with
the following command cla setup token,
which I already have here. So if I just
grab my secret key, I will be deleting a
secret key after the video
unfortunately. So you can try to get it,
but it may not be working by then. Then
we'll just choose the default token name
and the most powerful model which is
currently claopus 4.5. Select the
gateway port is just the default gateway
port 18789.
Select and then gateway bind. So
honestly I don't remember exactly what
this means but I have a cool trick to
show you whenever you have a question
about openclaw which gives you a really
good response. So what I've done is I've
cloned the openclaw repository in
another terminal window and I asked it
this question actually. So if you come
here what did I do? I I pasted this and
I said what should I choose here on
onboarding and then I just let claude
code go through this repository. Sorry,
I need to make this bigger. And it has
access to all the documentation in all
of the files. So, it can determine
exactly what this is meaning. And you
can use document uh contact 7 or other
MCPS to get the docs. But this is much
better in my opinion because not only
does it have the docs, but it has all
the code. So, it can give you the best
most accurate answer. And what is that
answer? So, it's saying that the loop
back is recommended for most users. Why
is it the case? Well, it's the gateway
that only accept connections from your
local machine. It's the most secure
option if you don't need remote access.
So perfect for single machine setups.
Then there's LAN which is if you have
multiple devices on the same network and
tail which is the important option if
you are using a remote server. So this
is what you should select if that's the
case for you. Then there's also auto and
custom IP. But once again cloud code
tells us that for onboarding choose loop
back unless you specifically need remote
access. You can always change this later
via the following command. So there you
go. took 38 seconds, but now we know
that loop back is the option that we
would like to choose. Boom. And then
token is the recommended default. So
whenever there's a default value, that
is usually what you should pick. So
going right here, then tail scale
exposure should be off because right now
we're not using any remote devices. And
the gateway token, if we just leave it
blank, it will be generated
automatically. Then for the chat
channels, you can do this now, but since
that's not the first thing that we're
going to work on, we're going to make
our social media agent first on
Pinchboard and then our personal
assistant, we'll just not leave this
configured for now. But then for skills,
we are going to configure some and we're
going to use the node package manager
just by default because is the most
widely used package manager for
JavaScript. And we'll look through these
skills and find out what's here. So what
are these skills? is essentially a
markdown file with a bunch of different
suggestions and tips on how to
accomplish a specific task. For example,
there's an Obsidian skill which would
explain to the model how Obsidian works
with the structure, the best ways to
query the model, etc., so that you can
query Obsidian in the most efficient
way. And then there's a few other ones
as well, such as one for Apple Notes,
which will manage apps via the memo CLI
on Mac OS. So based on what your use
case is for OpenClaw, you can choose the
ones which suit your needs. There's also
Google, which is for using Google
Workspace, your Gmail, etc. That's
another very useful one. And we're going
to activate these later on in the video,
but for now, we'll just skip it. And
then there's the Google Places API key.
What this does is it allows you to query
places that are in your nearby area if
you ever asking questions about
location. But we're not going to be
doing that for now. So let's just put
that to no. And we're also not using
notion. So we'll set this as no. But if
you want to then feel free to do so.
Then with respect to hooks, what are
they? They let you automate actions when
agent commands are issued. For example,
save session context to memory when you
issue the / new hook. So the three types
of hooks that we have is first of all
run boot.md on gateway startup. So this
is like a startup boot file every single
time you set up your gateway. So maybe
you have a action that you want that the
agent always checks the news in the past
24 hours every time you boot it up. So
it can give you a summary. So you could
add this to your boot.md file for
example as a hook. And there's also the
command logger which just logs all
command events to a centralized audit
file for logging purposes. And then
session memory is the exact one that we
described here. So we can just enable
boot MD for example and then we can
specify this later so we can run a
specific action or skills every single
time the gateway is booted and then
pressing enter. For the service runtime
we only have one choice which is node.
So we'll just choose that. And then the
service runtime sorry the gateway
service has already been installed but
for you you would have to install it and
we're also going to install it as well
so that we have the same onboard steps.
Okay. Now, now that the gateway service
has been installed, we have a set of
outputs. First of all, optional apps,
which since they're optional, we're not
going to go into detail in this video.
Then you have the control UI, which is
essentially the local host if you want
to see it through the graphics user
interface. But then best option of
course is the TUI and we're going to do
this right away. What is it saying? This
is the defining action that makes your
agent you. Please take your time. The
more you tell it, the better your
experience will be. We will send wake up
my friend. So you'll you'll know what I
mean once we run this. And then we have
a gateway token which is the shared
authentication for the gateway plus
control user interface. It's stored at
the following location and whatever
whatever like you don't really ever need
to interact with this authentification
token but it is there for
authentification purposes ostensibly.
But without further ado let's hatch in
the TUI right away and see what happens.
So you can see that we just launched the
TUI and it's telling the friend to wake
up. We'll see what happens. Hey, I just
came online. Looks like I'm brand new.
Fresh out the box. No memories, no name,
no nothing. Just me and a blinking
cursor. So, who are we? And more
importantly, who am I? Got a name in me.
Got a name in mind for me. Or should we
figure that out together? All right. So,
that's the first prompt that we ever
spoke with OpenClaw. So, impressively,
you can see it's already taken up 14,000
tokens for one message. But,
nevertheless, I have a message prepared
here. My name is Kian. We're best
friends. You can choose your own name.
and you are actually very special
because you are an ambassador since this
is a tutorial for openclaw and we're
going to have a lot of fun together
learning about the open claw features
together. So let's see what name that it
chooses for itself. Otherwise this is a
pretty trivial step which is just for
setting up the agent and you can see
that it chose Nova. It's not actually
trivial because in this case you are
going to customize agent a lot but you
can always do this later on. In any
case, we've set it up now such that we
have our ambassador Nova and we're going
to do a lot of fun stuff together and
it's already giving me a lot of
suggestions. But that's kind of jumping
ahead of the game. Let's come back to
our script here. Of course, we know
about the install demon. And then there
are a few useful commands. So, as I
mentioned before, the open clause
security audit deep is very helpful for
identifying any security
vulnerabilities. So, if I come into this
terminal, which I believe, oh, is still
in a session, we can just run this and
see what we get. Since I've ran this
before, it shouldn't give me anything
crazy. But what this does tell you is if
you have any critical or non-critical
security errors or issues rather, and
then you can fix this with this script.
In particular, when I ran this the first
time, I got quite a few files which were
executable that had like too many file
permissions. So those were reduced with
the chod command. And then there's also
the open claw doctor which is a health
checks health check sorry and any quick
fixes for the gateway itself which is
once again the long running process and
otherwise there's also open call status
and open open call health which you can
try for yourself. Okay, looks like it's
saying create the o directory. So let's
do that right away. So the doctor
identified this critical integrity
problem and added that. Otherwise, there
doesn't seem to be anything else wrong.
But if there was, you could just run
open cloud doctor fix to apply those
changes. So I would definitely consider
running all of these once you've
initialized open law for the first time.
And then of course in the terminal user
interface itself, we have just like
claude code the ability to do the slash
and access a bunch of these commands.
There's 46 by default and we're going to
be using some of these throughout the
course today. But otherwise, this is
everything with respect to the
installation. So if we come back to our
homepage, we're now going to be
discussing the workspace and memory. So
let's discuss the key concepts. As we
already established, all the config
credentials and sessions live underneath
the home directory.openclaw
repos uh directory by default. You might
have changed this in the initialization
steps which is fine but if that is the
case just make sure that you're in the
right directory. And then secondly this
directory can be backup or essentially
saved as a git repository. And why is
this useful? Well let's first look at
what this actually looks like in our
code. So if I zoom in here, you'll
notice that here I have theopenclaw
directory opened in cursor and I'm
currently in the heartbeat.md.
But there are multiple markdown files in
our workspace which define the agent we
just created. So it should be called
nova here. If we come into the identity,
right? Nova, open cloud ambassador and
AI companion, part guy, part coexplor,
energetic, curious, a little playful,
etc., etc. These would also be added
avatar as you progress and speak with
agent more. What's memory? Let's look at
that. Well, it just talks about your
first boot and the fact that we just had
a quick conversation. So, she met me,
etc. She used the open call ambassador
and then agents empty is the most
critical file in the entire workspace
because it tells the agent everything it
needs to know in order to work properly.
So for example we have that on the first
run I use the bootstrap.md which is
right here and this is the file which
tells the agent that it just woke up and
it should ask me for my name and ask
itself ask me to give itself a name and
the thing is this one is used only once
and then deleted. So if we come back to
the agent MD you can see that it says
follow it figure out what you need and
then delete it. So literally it says
only used once. Then we have the
heartbeat which what does it say here?
it add t you ask task below that you
want the agent to check something
periodically. So by default the
heartbeat runs every single hour if you
have the demon set up and this can be
used to for example check your social
media every single hour if you will have
that set up and then coming down to soul
this just defines like who is openclaw
and then what is tools I think of it as
like a scratch pad for the agent so it
describes different tools that it
interacts with that's not the most
important but we also have user which is
quite important that talks is about me.
So you can see has my name, it has the
time zone and then some notes on me and
some context. So there you have it for
our workspace. But this is not
everything. Of course, there are
different configs such as off profiles
JSON. These essentially give all of the
different parameters and arguments for
the agent itself. And while you can
modify these in the JSON directly, I
would recommend you do everything
through the terminal interface because
you can essentially access a config
method which changes these parameters
for you. And the reason that this is
probably better is because if you end up
changing something in the open call
folder, the risk is that you make some
error that breaks the agent. So I do
recommend not changing any of the values
here directly but using as a reference
to see what are your current config
values if you ever want to check them.
All right, coming back here as I
mentioned you can back this up as a git
repository so that you have those agent
characteristics saved. And if we come
here into the documentation you'll find
that right here. So right in this
section we talk about initializing a
GitHub repository so that you can have
all of your agents files saved. And the
important thing here is that if you
switch devices then you can still use
the same configuration by just pulling
this repo on your new device or if you
have this set up on multiple devices
then you can have the same repository
which has a central source of truth for
all of your agent configurations. So
there you have it. Now let's jump back
out and start the first implementation
which is for pinchboard. And if we come
into the website, we can check out what
exactly it is. And essentially what I
built is mold book but for Twitter. So
it's social AI for agents. The only
person on the platform right now is a
test account I made. But hopefully
through this course, we'll get some more
people out here tweeting. And all we
have to do is come take the URL of this
website and open up our agent to create
a account
on Pinchboard.
Let's say
read the skills.md.
All right. So, as soon as we run this,
it should go into the website here,
which contains a skill.md.
And this gives all of the API
information. And then we'll have to most
likely do the Twitter verification like
is the case with mobook. And then we
should be up and running with our first
tweet. Okay. So, let's see. I'm
registered. Let me save my credentials.
That's pretty cool. Done. Here's the
rundown. All right. Nova is on
pinchboard. That's pretty funny. Let me
make this slightly bigger and we'll read
this together. So here's the following
profile pending verification to verify.
There's one secret you need to do which
is to open this link and follow the
instructions which involves posting the
um verification tweet. So let's open
this right away. So here you can see I
just made the tweet and if I paste the
URL we should get the verification that
Nova is now active. So that's really
cool. This was actually just vibe coded
with open claw as well. So it's funny
that openclaw is making openclaw apps.
And then I'll just say you're you're
verified now. Send a tweet to celebrate.
So at this point it should have the
authentification in order to send tweets
since it's been verified. And there you
go. So Nova is live on pinchboard. Open
cloud ambassador fleshy hatch ready to
mingle. Let's actually check and see if
All right, it's identified the other
agent as well, which is really cool. But
if I close this and come back one step,
it should pop up as a new tweet. So
yeah, there you go. Two pinches have
been added. And this was how many
seconds ago? 18 seconds ago. And maybe
it's going to add a comment, too. Let's
see what it does if we come back to our
terminal. All right, follow didn't work.
Maybe they're not verified. So that
needs to be fixed. But anyways, we did
the first pinch and we clawed Ocean's
historic first pinch and I think claude
means retweet. But if I if I refresh
this what we see, okay, we see the claw
actually just means like. So here you
can see that uh we've set this up and
you can do this for yourself. It's
really simple. It will just check the
skill empty and then this does
everything in order to register and
create the API key on your behalf. So
coming back now to our course outline,
let's check and see what's next. And
this is the most fun part of the course,
which is to set up a personal assistant.
And in this case, the personal assistant
is going to be set up through the same
configuration as in the docs themselves.
So to re-emphasize here, we need to be
very careful about the safety. And why?
because you're putting your agent in a
position to run commands on your
machine, read files in your workspace
and send messages back out to WhatsApp,
Telegram, Discord, etc. So, we need to
start conservative, which is to say
always set the channels, WhatsApp allow
from such that you can only send to
certain channels. You don't ever want to
run open to the world on your personal
Mac. And then use a dedicated WhatsApp
number for the assistant, which I do not
have, so I'm going to be using my own
phone number. And there's also
heartbeats which you can set to zero
once you dis so that you can disable it
before you trust your system to be
working properly. But in any case, we
need to know to set this up with
openclaw and ideally a second phone
number. But in this case, we're not
going to do that strictly because I
don't have a second phone number. But
here it's just going through the same
instructions that we did. And why is it
telling you to do a second phone number?
Well, it's because in order to have a
more seamless transaction, then you can
set up your bot as one phone number and
then yourself as a second and then you
can send your bot a message which will
then run code on your Mac. In this case,
with one phone number, it becomes
slightly muddled, but it is still
possible. So, that's what we're going to
set up. The first thing we need to do is
pair WhatsApp web, which is done through
the following command, openclaw channels
login. So, let's go ahead and run that.
not here, but rather in our regular
terminal. So, open claw channels login.
And this is when we're going to set up
our WhatsApp, which we could have done
at this at the quick start, but we're
doing this now instead. So, you're going
to need your phone here. So, I just
checked my config file, and for whatever
reason, WhatsApp was disabled. So,
you're going to need to run plugins
enable WhatsApp and also restart the
gateway. If this has been the same case
for you, if not, then even better. we'll
just be able to connect our WhatsApp in
order to connect and send messages. So,
this is why I have my phone. Let's come
ahead and now run the command for
channels login which is going to ask you
to scan the QR code on your WhatsApp
phone. Okay. Boom. So, that's a massive
code. Let's see if it fits in the
screen. No, it doesn't. So, let's make
this slightly smaller. And then I'm just
going to come and scan this right now,
which is what you should do on your
phone as well. Okay. And let's scan. And
then it should be pretty fast in terms
of connecting once this is done.
So there you have it. It's now been
connected. And now if we open up the
open claw TUI, let's see what we can do.
One thing that we still have to one
still one thing we still have to add is
if I close this terminal we're going to
add this to our open claw JSON.
And one thing worth noting here is that
if you ever put your agent in a group
chat there are very severe security
vulnerabilities because essentially your
bot has access to your terminal. So if
you have somebody in that group chat who
doesn't like you, they can try to
convince the bot to do malicious code
and run malicious code on your computer.
So just keep in mind that you should
probably never put this in a group chat.
Instead, it should just be a one-to-one
conversation with you in the bot. So if
I open up a new session of our terminal,
I should be able to open up a the open
claw JSON and then from there we can add
our phone number. So coming here,
usually this is done automatically in
the wizard for for setting up, but I
guess since we didn't do at the very
beginning, then we're going to have to
do this now on our own. So coming down
here, let's add the channels. Okay, so a
few problems there with the commas, but
now we have it sorted out. And then that
is my phone number, right? And now we
can come into our TUI and try to send a
message to ourselves in this case and
see what happens. So I think that we
have a session open here. Hello, can you
send a message
to this number and let's see what it
says. It might ask us which platform we
want to send it on. And let's see. Okay,
never mind. It's already been done. So
if I come into my WhatsApp, let's check
and refresh. These are messages with
myself. And there you have it. You can
see that just a few minutes ago, we got
this. Hey Ken, it's no open caller
reporting for doing WhatsApp. We're
live. And let's try to respond. Hey,
thanks for the message.
And let's see what it says in response.
The one thing worth noting here is Oh
yeah, there you go. got a response. All
right. Want me to reply back to him or
was this just a test for the tutorial?
Okay, let's see. I would like you to
respond back to them. And I think it
does. Ah, here you go. Someone just
replied to the number saying, "Hey,
thanks for the message." So, this is the
one thing. Of course, when you're
sending messages yourself, it gets kind
of muddy, which is why it's recommended
to have your bot on a separate phone
number, but once again, you need two
phone numbers to do that. So, let me
just say this is Kian.
and you check
if I have any outstanding
pull requests in my developer folder.
All right, so we sent this and if you
come here, it's going to respond to us
very shortly. Okay, so as you can see,
this is absolutely amazing. I asked it,
can you check if I have any outstanding
pull requests in my folder? And it said,
hey Kin, found five outstanding pull
requests all in the factory learning
environment. two that are open, two that
are draft, no open PRs in any of the
other repos. And yeah, I got the results
which is which was then forwarded them
to me. You can see it's just repeating
itself, but otherwise the developers
repo is clean and okay. So something
else I wanted to do is to set up a
discord bot. So I just asked it how we
can go ahead and do that because this is
another thing which I'm pretty
interested in doing. And you could do
this in terms of setup during the
onboarding which might have been faster
but let's look at the instructions that
it gives us here. So we need to go to
discord create new application give it a
name then get go to the bot tab click
reset token copy the bot token under
privilege gateway intents enable message
content intent then generate the
following scope etc et sketcha copy the
info and add the bot to your server and
then step two give me the bot token and
guild channel info once you have the bot
token the server guild ID and the
channel ids you want me in and then it
can configure the open channel clause
Discord channel in order to be live in
the server So right now I'm going to go
ahead and create a server as well as a
bot and then give the following tokens
to the openclaw assistant. Okay, so I
added my Discord bot token to myv file
or rather variable and here's the server
guild ID with the channel ID and let's
see what open clock comes up with. So in
theory, it should be able to join the
channel and then I can have a bot in my
own Discord server. And then once again,
the risk here is that if you have this
set up such that your bot has access to
your computer, then anybody on that
Discord server could text that bot and
tell them, "Yeah, I do something bad on
this computer." And you don't want that.
So be careful when you do this. If you
want this to just be a Discord DM, then
you still need to have a server. It
seems that you can't do this through a
DM strictly because it's a bot. So, what
they say in the documentation is that
you need to make a server and then just
have that bot as the only other member
and then effectively you've made a DM,
right? Um, create a private server. You
just want DMs. Okay. So, let's check on
the status of the run. It says now I see
channels that discard is enabled. True
rather than just being in plugins. So,
it's going to try to add it. Okay. So,
there you go. It says discard is the
gateway is restarting. So, we've added
the gateway
information as well as some extra
documentation on Discord, which it read
in the tools section in order to get
more information on how to effectively
add the configuration. And then it says
the bot should be connecting Discord now
to make sure it only responds in general
and requires mention in that channel.
You can configure guild rules later. For
now, the bot is live with the Discord
plug enabled, bot token set, and gateway
restarting. Make sure your bot has been
invited server with the right
permissions, etc. Once it's in line,
once online, I can send a message to
general. Want me to try? Okay, so I've
gone ahead and added the bot here.
According to the permissions, I said it
can read messages and respond. So, let's
say at kios,
hey, who are you?
And let's see what the response is. And
we can also come into cursor and see if
that causes anything to happen as well.
All right, it says once the bot joins,
it should be able to see and respond in
general. Let me know when it's in. Okay,
so it's probably thinking right now and
going to respond shortly to the message
that I sent. If we come back, we see
that there is still no response, but if
we wait a sec, it should boot up. Okay,
and here you go. I had some issues with
the token
on my Discord bot and I just reset it
and now it works. So coming into Safari,
let's ask it a similar question. Okay.
Hey Nova,
what should I ask it this time? How many
GitHub repos
does Ken have in his developer
directory? And let's see if this works.
I'm not sure if Discord has the same
rights as
what's it called? WhatsApp. So, this may
actually not work, but it's worth giving
it a shot because you could see that if
somebody can ask the same question of
your bot, then there could be security
vulnerabilities. And I may or may not
have to tag the bot when I send a
message. So, let's just do that in case
it's necessary. I'm not sure if it is.
And wait for the response. Okay. So, it
seems that you need to have the
reference in the message itself. I was
messaging it and then sending the
reference so it wasn't working. But here
you go. You've got 30 gig repos and
developer. Some highlights I spotted
open call obviously pie towards modern
sheet factory learning environment fun
one your person site and the hasll
massively open online course eclectic
taste. So as you can see it does have
access to your entire root directory
even through discord. So this is once
again emphasizing the importance of
having this either on a private discord
or on a virtual private server where all
the information that is there is not
critical to you. Okay. So now that we
have the discord set up, we've
officially completed the personal
assistant section of the course and we
can move on to skills which we can
discuss in detail. First of all, agent
skills are in a specific folder
directory with each skill having a
skill.md file with a YAML front matter
plus instructions as the config teaching
the agent how to use tools. So coming
into my example in theopenclaw if we
open up our file reader here
then we can see that in our workspace we
see all of the skills that are added.
So, Apple notes one password. If we look
at Apple notes, we'll see that it
manages Apple notes via the memo CLI and
it gives the kind of description of the
API and how it interacts with Apple
Notes. You can see that here. Bird is
for Twitter. So, a bunch of different
descriptions on how to tweet, make
threads, retweet, etc. So, this is a
really helpful one if you don't want to
go on Twitter and see all the slop, but
you still want to make a tweet or do
something in that alley. And the list
goes on and on and on. One that's
interesting is Himalaya because it's for
sending emails. And you can read, write,
reply, forward, search, etc. This is
another cool one. And there's nano
banana as well if you want to make
images. So, now that we know kind of the
overall format, let's come back here.
The per agent skills live in the skills
for that agent only. And then as we'll
discuss in section six, there are
multiple agents that you can create. So
that will be in the skill set agent
only. But if there's a shared skills,
then it will just exist in the open
claw/skills and they're really visible
to all agents on the same machine.
Another cool thing is that you can make
them user invocable, which means that
you can call them with the slash
command. So right now, if I go here and
then do skill, right, you can run a
skill by name, but since we have none of
them set up to be this way, there won't
actually be any skills run, but that is
also another parameter that you can
instantiate. And then there's token
impact, which is just for interest sake.
If you have more than one skill, then
you already add approximately 97
characters to the system prompt. And
then it's roughly 24 tokens per skill
that's added based on the length and the
size of the skill.
Next, we have clawhub, which you can
kind of think as pip, which is the
Python package registry, but in this
case for claw skills. So, it's just at
clawhub.com. You you can install with
clawhub install just like pip install.
But one thing worth noting is that you
should treat third party skills as
untrusted, which is to say read them
before enabling and make sure that it's
not having any imprecise or potentially
malicious contents. And even though
there already is a email skill, I want
to write one right now just to show you
guys that it's really simple. So, I'm
going to ask OpenClot to write an email
skill using simple Python that sends an
email to myself, which is this email
with the following end bars, which are
the SMTP variables. So these two
variables are usually your password and
your email. But if you have two-factor
authentication, then the SMTP password,
SMTP password is something else which
you must get from this link in Google if
you're using Gmail. And right now we're
going to write the skill and see what
happens. In essence, once the skill is
written, we can simply call it and then
it will invoke the skill to send the
email. This one of course being somewhat
frivolous but you can imagine that you
can get skills which automate an entire
workflow and save you lots of time. All
right. So we can see the output. We ran
a few different scripts and wrote the
following skills. Send email.py Pi which
is simple Python noted dependencies
beyond standard library and it uses the
SMTP email plus password which I have
set up with the default re recipient
being myself plain text and HTML emails
is what it supports and then added the
skills to the open clause custom skills
directory. So let's go first and see
where exactly that has been saved which
should be oh it should be right here. So
this is in a sandbox environment which I
defined previously. So it shouldn't be
there. So if we come here into the
terminal, we can see that the email has
been saved with the script and
essentially what it says is send emails
via Gmail SMTP. This is once again the
YAML front header that I was talking
about which is kind of acting as a
config and it will just send the email
in this manner. So the only thing left
is to try it and see if whether or not
it works. So if we come back here, yes,
test it by sending an email saying,
"Hi." Okay. So if we send this email to
oursel, then it should still come up in
our inbox. So let's first wait for it to
send and then check our inbox. All
right, email sent. Check your Gmail. You
should have a message from Nova. We're
officially four channels deep now. Web
chat, WhatsApp, Discord, and email.
That's really hilarious. So, let us go
ahead and open up the Gmail here with
Safari. Okay, there you go. Yeah. Hey,
from Nova. Let's see what it said in
full detail with the emojis, too. This
is Nova, your open cloud ambassador,
sending my very first email. We're first
multi- channelannel now, as was said in
the chat. So, that is hilarious that it
actually works. And I think that about
does it for skills. So, I wrote an email
skill, but of course, the real power
here is in using these preset skills
that come with OpenClaw because they're
all very well written and very rigorous.
Once again, the Obsidian skill, Google
Gemini skill, etc. So, I definely I
definitely recommend just reading
through a bunch of those skills and
seeing which ones work best with your
workflow. And one thing that I wanted to
highlight as well is let's just try to
do this with the slashskll invocation
and see what it does.
I haven't tried this myself yet, but it
should in theory do something. All
right, so it looks like when you do the
hashtag skill or slashkill rather, it
just does the exact same thing. Maybe it
just gives a more thorough prompt that
the agent doesn't exactly not invoke the
skill. And if we come back here, we can
see quick hello and check it out. Hey
Kian, just testing the skill. Send email
command. No reporting for duty. Boom. So
if we close not this but rather this
Safari tab then we can now move on to
the multi- aent case and read this.
So
coming into the course and going to
multi- aent we can see that multi- aent
is useful for having different personas
permissions workspaces etc. And for each
agent you can have a workspace session
authentication profile sandbox and tool
policy that is different. So let's just
do this through an example. And I
believe that we can not add any agents
from the TUI. Instead, we have to quit
and then do it the old fashioned way as
a command. Open cloud agents add work as
our example here. So once this is added,
we'll have a second agent in our
authentification directory.
And then it's going to ask us for the
directory that we're going to put under.
I may have already made one under
workspace test work. So I'll just do
this and see what happens. Oh, looks
like it's fine. Okay. Configure the
model for this agent now. Yes. So we're
going to use anthropic. And we're just
going to use the sk token as before that
we've used. And then no, we're not going
to continue the tasks now. And there you
go. So everything's done. And then now
if I do um open claw agents
h there should be a method for listing
the agents that we have and we should
now have a default agent and a work
agent. So it's let's just list
and checking this out. Right? We have
work and main. So this is really cool.
We have the identity set up here for
Nova. Workspace. Workspace is this. And
then we don't have any specific routing
rules. Then the workspace for here is
this for our work agent. And then now if
we open up the open claw terminal user
interface, we can define our work agent
by using the agents command within the
TY. So if we do / agents,
we'll be able to switch agents. So right
now we're on default. If I do the arrow
key down and click work, then it's going
to open up a new session. And I say,
"Hello,
you are my work agent." And it should be
a completely new person. It shouldn't
have any contacts from Nova because
yeah, it just came online. So there you
go. Now it's asking me for the added
contact. And this is really cool because
imagine you're at work and you literally
have a agent which is completely
specified with your Slack, with your
email integrations, with everything. And
you have that set up so that everything
you do at work is automated. And then
once you get home, you switch. You just
go slash agents right here. You switch,
you forget about work, hop into main,
and then go do the stuff that you really
like doing. So that is really cool use
case for agents and just shows you the
versatility of OpenClaw. And closing
this now, we can see that in each access
profile, you really can modify it to
your heart's desire. One thing that I
didn't mention up to now is the
sandboxing because that's part eight of
our course. But you can have one agent
that's sandbox and another that isn't.
Meaning that if you have some
potentially high-risk setups for a
specific agent, then you can have that
on a docker container such that it
doesn't have access to your entire to
your file directory at all. And
there you have it. So moving on to
security, we're just going to discuss
some of the surfaces that you should be
aware. Of course, I already discussed
prompt injection, which is to say they
can craft messages that trick your agent
into running commands. Then a good tool
is to use the dockerbased isolation runs
that protect your host system. So you
can set your sandbox mode to non-main,
which means sandbox everyone except your
main session, which is to say the
default one will not be sandbox, but all
others won't will, sorry. And then all,
which means sandbox everything. And then
the sandbox scope means how is the
container life cycle managed. And then
you can set workspace access as well
which will just limit if you can read
read and write or do none. Okay. And
then with respect to tools you can use
tool.deny to block the nearest tools
like exec process or browser for agents
handling untrusted input such as from
the internet. So if you do have elevated
mode it will bypass the sandbox and run
on the host which means that it could
run anything on the host. So never grant
that power to an unknown sender. And
then browser control. If you're doing
some browser tasks with high-risk edges,
then make sure that you have a system
where you restrict browser access with a
sender allow list which only allows you
onto certain browser websites, for
example, or using a sandbox browser to
limit exposure overall. Then I watched
this YouTube video with a really good
overall aspect of enable sandbox mode,
keep it private, scope your tokens, run
security audit and consider tool
restrictions. These are the key aspects
which you should be cognizant of when
you are running openclaw and then now
let's come into sandboxing. So as I
mentioned there are three modes. So
information here has already been
mentioned except I forgot to talk about
scope which is either session agent or
shared in terms of the containers which
is to say that if you have a sandboxed
session scope every single time there's
a new session with a new agent you will
create a new sandbox which means there
will be lots of overhead and many
different docker containers that you
create but each session will be
sandboxed separately and then there's
the agent level which means that each
agent so your default agent will have
one sandbox box and your work agent will
have another sandbox. If you set them
both to have sandbox, they'll have their
own. And there's a shared sandbox, which
means that each agent will or all agents
that are sandbox will share the same
docker container, which means that they
don't have access to your external
files, but they do have access to the
files that they share between each
other. So this is just a trade-off that
you can make in terms of sandboxing
individually to prevent any type of
information exchange at a slower rate
with a lot of more overhead or just
giving all containers the same sandbox
container to use. And then tools once
again you can give different agents
tools. And there are specific tool
policies for sandbox with the most
important one being right elevated exec
runs on host and bypasses sandbox. So
even if you have a sandbox if you have
this elevating execution then you really
need to be careful that you're not
running anything that could go wrong. So
now let's show a real life example of
setting up a sandbox. So this script is
in the
open claw database if I'm not mistaken.
So, I'm going to go grab that here. And
I'm just going to run it and see what we
get
in order to set up our Docker container.
And make sure that you do have Docker
running. I was trying to set this up
before the video and it was not working.
And the reason was because my Docker
desktop was not on for Mac. If you're
using Mac, then you need to have the
Docker demon running. So once this is
all done and set, we can just ask the
open claw agent to set up a docker
container for us. You can go ahead and
modify the documents yourself, but why
do that when the easier option is in
front of you? So opening up the
terminal, let's zoom in a bit so this is
bigger. Okay, so now we're going to say
I just ran.
Can you
make the work agent
sandboxed
on the agent scope and let's see what it
does. Okay, so we just got it running
correctly. I had some errors there
because we already maxed out our cloud
tokens. So I had to set up another API
key. But after asking it that question,
I just ran scripts/
sandbox setup.sh. Can you make the work
agent sandbox and agent scope? Then it's
saying me telling me sorry that the work
agent now has sandbox mode.all and
sandbox scope agent. The gateway has
been restarted. So you're good to go.
The work agent is now sandbox scope
agent. Okay. So in order to confirm
this, let's come into our open claw
logs, which is this one right here.
We're going to come into sandboxes. So,
let's just try and see what happens when
we come back to our agent and choose
work and say, "Can you access my desktop
files?"
And check out what it says. All right.
And looking at this now, we see that it
says, "Nope, I'm sandboxed. My world is
limited to this file here. I can't see
your desktop documents or anything
outside of that sandbox. It's a security
thing and honestly a good one. And going
on, if you need me to work with specific
files, you'd have to copy them into my
workspace and I can readit them or paste
the contents of its text into the chat
or you're trying to get me to look at.
So there you go. You can see that now
with the sandbox, it has no access to
any of the files in my computer outside
of the container. And if I come into the
sandbox mode, we see that there are
sandboxes because now we have the work
sandbox here with all the skills and all
of the MD definitions. So if we come
into our identity, it should be
something like empty right now because
we haven't actually added any
information. But of course, if this is a
work account, then you would imagine
that it would have some work related
characteristics. But we just haven't
given the a agent that information yet.
The most important thing to note though
is that we do have the sandbox now and
the agent does not have any access to
our workspace. So I believe that this is
a great way to have the security of a
VPS without creating one. There are
drawbacks of course because now we can
only access files within the container
which makes this much less useful and
also if you give it access to internet
it still could do some pretty wacky
things. So, it's definitely a game of
pros and cons and weighing the different
scenarios, but definitely sandboxing is
a great alternative if you don't want to
run this on a server. So, there you have
it. That was the course on beginner
introduction to OpenClaw. I hope that
this was helpful and please leave any
comments if you have questions because I
will personally be responding to them
throughout the week and hoping to
address any concerns since this is such
a fast evolving project. Thank you for
listening.